even in the huge gigs you do you do use
the audience and in the take the ground
or there was one bit where you always
took someone out to the audience got
them up on stage you know the bit I'm
talking about yeah so that was this I
think this was in Sweden where you found
the girl who written the sign and then
you did bless you you are so nice you
actually found her and as luck would
have it a very pretty awesome that
didn't go unnoticed on the evening did
you get a tattoo did she get the I think
so yeah I think she did get the tattoo
she looks a bit like Kate Marsh who's
gorgeous her name probably somewhere
it's Lou Lou loony loony Martinson but
the weird thing is and that was in
Sweden but apparently she lives in
Norway
yeah she did I barely chew up tattoo and
the other thing she's got is Skype huh
let me get scrolling up now
well there she is ha
is it is that noni is it Loney Loney you
got it right I got it right
learning learning okay Unni loony sorry
for the birthday so now and by the way
there's there's mr. Williams he said can
you see him in the distance there hello
Don nice to see you again so a so loony
but it did you did you do it yeah I got
it done Sunday today after ok now I feel
a bit like dr. Christian and
embarrassing buddies
if you like to ease your pants down
this does not sound like the kind of
thing a BBC presenter she sang in the
same
all right all right just to learn I do
you mind showing us okay this is like
every webcam experience I've ever had
honey move your hand there it is Oh
thank you very much for me bye darling
take care ah
Oh
go
that's a crazy level of pain
by the way can you think no no I can't
at all no but that's never stopped me
times I've turned up to places and the
look on people's faces they realize I'm
not Robin Williams